oi gente boa tarde
é vamos aproveitar que está todo mundo
aqui morto
no país almoço e vamos dar uma
denominada tal é quem é que já virou uma
noite fazendo algum trabalho da
faculdade
caramba quem aqui por algum acaso já
tomou alguma espécie de estimulante até
um remédio para conseguir dar conta da
carga de trabalho culpada e quem aqui
falando em cuba já se sentiu culpado por
estar descansando durante um final de
semana ou feriado ao invés de estar
trabalhando pois é
aos 22 anos de idade
eu tentei fazer uma coisa que uma pessoa
que eu gosto muito chama de tentar
abraçar o mundo com uma perna só
eu tinha acabado de entrar no escritório
que é exatamente da área que eu gostava
e incutir na minha cabeça com toda força
que eu podia e eu precisava naquele
estágio ser efetivada
eu precisava como estava mais pro final
da graduação eu já tinha começado a
fazer o terceiro
o que acontece é o meu orientador foi
demitido e por uma série de questões não
conseguiu outro lutador a tempo e não
conseguiu entregar o primeiro capítulo
do meu tcc por conta disso eu vi que eu
não ia me formar tempo
meu deus não vamos formar tempo não foi
informada tempo não vou conseguir entrar
no escritório que eu quero não conseguiu
entrar no escritório eu quero acabou a
minha vida
por conta disso é durante a metade final
de 2016
eu desenvolvi síndrome do pânico no mês
de dezembro eu tinha ataque de pânico
diários e eu perdi 10 quilos em um mês
em janeiro eu já não tinha mais
condições de trabalhar e continuar
estudando então é eu simplesmente tive
que sair do escritório
foi um caso isolado então juliana é você
não só não é um caso isolado como é
muito mais freqüentes do que você pode
imaginar e no início
e 2018
é acho que as coisas pra baixo
aqui é assim no início de 2008
uma pesquisadora americana chamada
teresa teresa evans fez ela fez uma
proposta de fazer uma avaliação de
sintomas ansiosos e depressivos em pós
graduandos de diversas universidades é
americanas
ela conseguiu uma mostra de em torno de
dois mil e trezentos pacientes
e olha que ela encontrou direito e no
mínimo é surpreendente veja só
enquanto na população normal a
incidência esperada de sintomas de
ansiedade e depressão
chega em torno de 6% na mostra de tereza
ii mas se queixaram de depressão 39% dos
pós-graduandos e de ansiedade chegou a
41% isso estamos considerando então pós
graduandos ou seja é uma faixa etária em
torno de 23 até mais ou menos uns 30
anos
olha essas taxas são bem alarmantes
porque isso é então vamos lá eu vou
mostrar um gráfico aqui isso aqui eu
acho que tem muito a ver com a
capacidade é de adaptação e há uma
relação íntima entre fatores causais e
uma mãe uma suscetibilidade é da faixa
etária né
veja aqui neste gráfico é um gráfico da
organização mundial de saúde e que em
2012 foi avaliado o risco de suicídio
com uma relação em relação à faixa
etária
então veja que a gente tem aqui um risco
maior de adoecimento entre os 15 e 30
anos que corresponde à faixa de de pós
graduandos da amostra do tereza aí você
também adolescentes é realmente você
chegou a falar de capacidade adaptativa
esse tabu de alguma forma relacionada à
faixa etária
então vamos lá antes queria perguntar
pra vocês
desculpa
antes eu queria perguntar pra vocês
viram aquela incidência alta de sintomas
depressivos e ansiosos né
quem é que acha que a culpa disso aí é
da universidade
levanta a mão aí quem acha que isso a
culpa individual é do aluno de adoecer
bom quem acha que nenhum dos dois
não na verdade está todo mundo certo
todo mundo errado que a gente tem aqui é
o seguinte
veja só é a capacidade adaptativa do ser
humano é muito ampla né gente a gente
consegue viver no espaço consegue viver
é no mar consegue viver no gelo no
deserto isso é uma capacidade inerente
nossa como espécie não é entretanto essa
capacidade ela precisa ser desenvolvida
durante a vida e durante o
amadurecimento humano nessa faixa etária
entre 15 e 30 anos ou seja adolescentes
e adultos jovens essa capacidade
adaptativa é muito baixa por conta de
uma fragilidade emocional uma baixa é
vivência não é essa fragilidade
emocional acaba interferindo não é no na
capacidade de resiliência da gente a
absorver impactos da vida é a estresse
da vida não é
esses impactos condições ouvidos
eles são mal resolvidos e vão
sucessivamente gerando novas
dificuldades e isso acaba dando um risco
maior para adoecer então na verdade não
é uma culpa nem da universidade e nem o
indivíduo é exatamente uma
suscetibilidade é da faixa etária de
maturidade associada uma alta demanda
que a universidade acaba casando e quais
seriam os maiores impactos ou fatores de
estresse mesmo pra quem está na
graduação então a a vida acadêmica é
repleta de grandes desafios e de grandes
estresses não é
veja começa quando a gente terminar o
ensino médio quando a gente terminar o
ensino médio a gente tem que esquecer
que tem que eleger uma profissão mas era
em que a gente elege uma profissão
baseada em que a não eu você agrônomo
você agrônomo porque você sabe
ser feliz fazendo economia o que é que
você vai fazer sendo agronomia não é
veja essa essas escolhas ela gera um
estresse né depois não é só isso aí você
vai fazer o vestibular
na época que você faz o vestibular você
tem uma concorrência imensa com várias
pessoas pra uma competição de uma vaga
ou de várias vagas não é
mas essa competição ela gera estresse
também se você passar ótimo
agora se você não passa tem que voltar
tudo de novo fazer tudo de novo mas
estresse ainda que você tem pra passar
mais desafio mais capacidade adaptativa
quando você entra na graduação a
história é outra
você tem que convocar tem que se formar
profissionalmente você tem que é ser
capacitado para entrar no mercado de
trabalho e ser um bom profissional
então você tem que aprender a trabalhar
em equipe você vai estudar um monte de
coisa que você não tinha e não tinha a
menor idéia de como é acabou aquela
história de vou estudar para passar no
eixo para passar de ano
você tem que se formar para você fazer
crescer o tc não é isso tudo você vai
requerer muito muito é a tua capacidade
adaptativa em uma faixa etária em que
isso não é é bem amadurecido boné sempre
é sempre mais difícil não é o próprio a
própria teresa saídas ela fez um
trabalho e em cima disso aí falando como
é que a interferência disso na sua
qualidade de vida
então olha só ela fez a seguinte
pergunta também para os alunos de pós
graduação
você consegue um bom equilíbrio entre a
sua vida pessoal eo trabalho e hora
também os resultados surpreendentes
veja dos pacientes que se queixaram de
depressão 56 por cento dizendo que não
conseguiam fazer um bom equilíbrio entre
a sua vida pessoal ea sua vida
profissional enquanto que aqueles que
sofriam de preto de ansiedade
chegava a 55 por cento então isso mostra
que existe uma dificuldade por conta da
sobrecarga de você equilibrar sua carga
a sua a sua vida emocional com a sua
vida a sua vida pessoal com a sua vida
profissional é como é que fica a
situação do mercado de trabalho é aí
mercado
trabalho a gente já tem um a paradigmas
maiores ainda né bom mercado de trabalho
como está aqui pra vocês é pra começar a
cada ano que passa a gente tem um número
maior de graduandos entrando no mercado
de trabalho não é tão veja em nesse
período entre 2006 até 2016 foram 40% a
mais de alunos formados entrando no
mercado de trabalho
você saiu de r 763 mil para um milhão e
quase 200 mil alunos ingressando no
mercado de trabalho
isso também pode ter se dado pelo
aumento populacional e pela facilidade
de acesso que surgiu nos últimos anos de
curso de graduação não há dúvida disso
não há dúvida problema é o seguinte como
é que essas pessoas vão ser absorvidas
no mercado de trabalho
a igreja aqui em todo mundo sabe que pra
você tem emprego você tem que ter uma
economia ativa né
aqui a gente vê isso nesse nesse neste
gráfico né
veja é quando a gente tem aqui uma uma
economia aquecida a gente tem bastante
nível de emprego
agora numa época recessiva não você
perde empregos e aí pegando exatamente
aquela época de 2016
veja aqui em 2016 tivemos uma época de
recessão não é e que foi e que se perdeu
1 milhão e 300 mil vagas
e aí olha o que acontece como é que a
gente vai absorver esses 1 milhão e 200
mil alunos que ingressam no mercado de
trabalho essa conta não fecha é não
fecha
ok é visto esse cenário por acaso a
gente tem centro de apoio de saúde
mental universitária então falar é de
saúde no brasil já é extremamente
complicado né
é difícil vamos falar de prevenção e
saúde
já é difícil prevenção e saúde mental é
mais difícil ainda agora imagina
prevenção em saúde mental na
universidade
se existe alguma coisa hoje são centros
muito raros
não é esse existem são informais
tá é realmente o cenário não parece
muito promissor
nem promissor imediatamente o prospecto
imediato disso não é de melhora
entretanto nosso intuito aqui não é
fazer todo mundo saiu disse esperançoso
e na atenção no meu deus do céu não tem
solução desse problema então existem
muitas coisas que podem ser feitas
é para que a gente possa melhorar nossa
capacidade adaptativa e funcionar bem na
sociedade
a primeira coisa organizar seu tempo e
equilibrar sua vida pessoal
gente vocês não precisam sentir culpado
por estar em descanso no final de semana
eo feriado taxou com um negócio que
talvez ninguém saiba inclusive eu também
não sabia eles foram feitos pra isso pra
descansar percebe baterias também né é
gastar é preciso a gente recarregar as
baterias
segunda coisa é reconhecer seus
problemas e evitar se isolar gente
reconhecer seus problemas têm uma faixa
do álbum você pode reconhecer seus
problemas e reconhecer que você talvez
não esteja conseguindo lidar com eles
não tem problema nenhum nisso evite se
isolar essa ajuda não se culpe por um
programa que você possa estar passando a
terceira coisa fale sobre o assunto
reclame reivindique a gente precisa
fomentar um debate sobre saúde mental
porque se esse debate não foi fomentado
se ninguém estiver falando sobre isso é
como se o programa não existisse e como
vocês podem ver no dia a dia esse
problema existe e está presente ele tem
se alastrado cada vez mais bem e para
buscar informação veja é imprescindível
o acesso á a a informação tá muito
disponível na internet
se você for procurar alguma coisa é
procure sempre é ter uma confiabilidade
naquilo que você está procurando então
procure sites técnicos em sites
técnicos universitários lá você vai ter
uma fuga uma informação mais filho
fidedigna e a respeito de qualquer
problema mental que você esteja
eventualmente passar bom
nica jamais em tempo algum se medic por
conta própria
as medicações ansiolíticos
antidepressivos estimulantes
elas têm efeito efeitos colaterais
inclusive podem até piorar o seu quadro
clínico
ó zé é a isso não seja é preconceituoso
preconceituoso com você mesmo é se você
tiver alguma dificuldade algum problema
de saúde procure um profissional da área
de saúde um psiquiatra um psicólogo eles
vão saber identificar o que você tá
tendo e vão para poder propor
alternativas e soluções para sua para
sua situação
é gente não é normal você tem que ficar
virando noite para fazer trabalho de
faculdade
não é normal você tem que tomar um
medicamento às vezes tarja preta para
conseguir dar conta da sua carga de
trabalho inclusive na normal você se
sente culpado por estar descansando
durante seu tempo de descanso
por isso é alguns graduandos criaram a
hashtag não é normal pra começar a falar
sobre esse assunto se vocês forem a rede
se vocês forem na internet buscarem essa
hashtag vocês vão encontrar diversos
posts com os quais vocês vão ter maior
dimensão da gravidade do problema que
tem se alastrado cada vez mais
portanto se você estiver passando por
alguma dificuldade na época da sua
graduação na época da pós graduação não
se espere isso aí é uma época que
realmente vai requerer muito da sua
capacidade adaptativa porque tem muita
sobrecarga emocional não é não se
desespere você vai se renovar isso vai
ajudar essa experiência vai ajudar você
mata a amadurecer como pessoa e
profissionalmente então você vai ter um
saldo positivo no final ela reconheça
seus limites e saiba que você pode
buscar uma solução de uma forma calma a
sua vida não acabou porque você
talvez não tenha se formado no tempo que
você achava que era certo porque não
existe um certo tempo é certa o seu e
não acha que a sua vida acabou por que
você não conseguiu emprego que você
achava que você deveria conseguir calma
então se você quiser resolver o seu
problema não transforma seu problema é
um tabu
procure ajuda e principalmente
precisamos falar sobre isso
[Aplausos]